hey I'm back today we're going to talk
about internment of fasting lower
carbohydrates and your thyroid many
times I'll hear from someone that it's
dangerous for your thyroid to do low
carbohydrates or fasting that's what
destroys the thyroid okay that is
absolutely not true
let me first kind of give you the basics
you have this thing called the pituitary
it's a small gland in your brain by the
size of a pea and it sends a message
down to the thyroid it controls the
thyroid thyroid at the base of the neck
right here it's about two and a half
inches wide it comes from the Latin word
which means shield because it looks like
a shield so this gland that's triggering
the main thyroid hormone is being
controlled by the pituitary through
something called the thyroid stimulating
hormone pretty much describes what it is
right so then the thyroid releases its
main hormone called t4 the four
represents the number of iodine
molecules so t4 is an inactive thyroid
hormone it has to be activated to make
it work and eighty percent of the
activation happens to the liver and 20%
happens to your kidney so what happens
when it gets activated through certain
enzymes it strips off an iodine and it
becomes t3 okay so t3 is the active form
of the thyroid hormone so t3 does its
job and it does has everything to do
with metabolism and speeding things up
and making things work through pretty
much all the cells so when it does its
job it sends a signal back up to the
pituitary complying with this order
completing the action and then this can
turn off so we have this whole feedback
system that's dependent on a lot of
different things the environment food
etc now it is true there are certain
things that will influence these
hormones like a low carbohydrate diet
and fasting can cause a low normal t3
okay that's active form it's not
necessarily abnormal but it could be low
normal ok still within the range okay
why would it be low normal simply
because T 3 is constant getting feedback
from the environment if you eat a lot of
food it has to speed up to keep up with
the metabolism if you eat less food
or less frequent food it can slow down
what you're gonna find is the thyroid
stimulating hormone is going to be
normal and this is how they diagnose a
hypothyroid problem okay so it's going
to be normal and t4 is probably gonna be
normal too you may just see a slight dip
in t3 and that is because you're not
consuming the frequent meals and the
quantities of sugar that you did before
and this is totally okay because your
body just doesn't need to produce the
quantities of t3 you may also see
another thing okay
higher reverse t3 now what is that what
what happens is if the body doesn't
necessarily need is much t3 it can put
it in an inactive form okay it's called
reverse t3 so t3 is kind of similar to
t4 it's just an inactive form of t3 now
why would this be higher because the
body is just adapting to the environment
it doesn't need as much t3 so it puts it
into an inactive form because if it did
keep going and you produce more and more
t3 when you didn't need it you can end
up with a hyperthyroidism okay if you
didn't have this and it kept going and
you produce too much t3 you can end up
with a hyper state the hyper thyroid
state now what happens when you go on a
little calorie diet okay and you don't
change your carbohydrates you have
higher months of carbohydrates like most
calorie diets do or even go through
stress or infection you could actually
have an alteration in the thyroid
stimulating hormone right here and you
can have low t3 and even low t4 but if
you're doing this if you're doing in a
minute fasting and you're losing weight
and you're on a low carbohydrate diet
and you're having energy and you're
feeling good and you're not hungry and
your hair is not falling out okay and
you find out that you have a low normal
but you have a normal thyroid
stimulating hormone just realize that
this is this is a totally okay situation
it's not gonna be a problem so one more
point I want to bring up about iodine
okay this is an iodine deficiency can
very easily create a hypothyroid state
but if you're taking a high quality seek
help that will protect the thyroid
iodine is very very good for women and
then it helps balance the estrogen out
also good for men
their prostate so it's a very vital
trace mineral alright guys thanks for
listening talk to you later so I hope
you're coming to the keto health summit
coming up in October so I want to
quickly comment on what we're gonna do
that's different from other conventions
okay
the problem with these other conventions
is they give you information over a load
okay it's so much data that you're
basically swimming in a sea of
information we're going to do things
very differently we're only going to
cover the most important things that
make a huge difference now there are
three very powerful strategies that
we're going to be talking about at the
summit that you will not find and any of
my youtube videos number one is on
memory I'm going to be showing you
something very cool to dramatically
increase your memory and concentration
that's going to blow you away and number
two I'm going to show you how to
increase your stress tolerance so you
are completely calm all the time
alright and number three and most
importantly if you have a slow
metabolism if you've died it for a long
time and everything is kind of just
really slow I'm going to show you how to
get complete control over your
metabolism so you can literally turn up
the dial as high as you want and control
as much weight as you want to lose and
these three things are just a tiny bit
of what you're going to learn in the
summit so click the link below get
signed up and I will see you in October